bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro deux check up votre
magazine santé bien-être ce mois ci nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de retraités
au mesnil saint denis
depuis quelques mois il bénéficie d'un
nouvel outil pour travailler leur
mémoire nous découvrirons également le
travail de plusieurs trappistes ont sur
la thématique du cancer du sein
mais tout d'abord le dossier de ce
nouveau numéro le don d'ovocytes
ce don consiste à aider les femmes qui
ont les ovocytes anormaux à vivre malgré
tout une grossesse en france en 2011
quatre cent de femmes ont donné leurs
ovocytes permettant près de 800
fécondation in vitro un acte légalisé en
france depuis 1994
nous avons rencontré un couple ayant
bénéficié de ce type 2 dont il s'était
rendu à l'hôpital de poissy le seul des
yvelines à prendre en charge ce type de
démarche
reportage luana vient de fêter son
premier anniversaire
ses parents profitent du moindre petit
instant de bonheur avec elle il n'y a
plus de dix ans aurélie et laurent
apprennent qu'ils ne pourront pas avoir
d'enfant naturellement après plusieurs
échecs de procréation médicalement
assistée leur médecin leur propose alors
le don d'ovocytes l'équivalent du
spermatozoïde chez l'homme pour aurélie
c'est l'une des dernières chances de
pouvoir vivre une véritable grossesse
son devoir passer par l'adoption
il accepte avance étape par étape et
c'est en avril 2012 après un an et demi
d'attenté qu'il reçoive finalement
l'appel du médecin l'appel leur
annonçant qu'ils ont prélevé six
ovocytes d'une donneuse anonyme et
qu'ils ont été mises en fécondation ici
au laboratoire avec les spermatozoïdes
de laurent deux embryons sont ensuite
implantés dans l'utérus d'aurélie
quelques semaines plus tard lorsqu'ils
sont en voyage
la future maman découvre qu'elle est
enceinte après quasiment dix ans de
d'attentes voilà c'est on a du mal à y
croire on se dit ah ouais c'est pense
moi je rêve et en même temps c'est
l'euphorie
on a attendu de revenir sur le
territoire français pour envoyer des
messages à tous nos amis à la famille
qui attendaient aussi des résultats avec
autant d'impatience que nous et et puis
voilà ça a été le début d'une autre
aventure avec au final les mêmes je
dirais condition qu'une grossesse
normale sauf que on va dire qu'il ya
peut-être ce petit plus qui fait qu'elle
est tellement extraordinaire que nous on
se dit qu'on a vraiment envie de la
vivre à 200 %
aurélie et laurent sont bien conscients
de la chance qu'ils ont eue de
bénéficier de ce dos c'est quand même un
véritable acte de générosité et que sans
ces personnes aujourd'hui il ya plein de
coupe qui n'auraient qui ne pourraient
pas vivre justement ce moment là pour
autant l'anonymat du don leur semble
primordial car au delà du côté génétique
luana reste avant tout leur bébé
clairement quand on porte le bébé qui
grandit en vous même si à l'origine à si
lula vient pas de vous
ça n'a aucune importance et c'est
vraiment c'est juste votre enfant quoi
c'est vous qui l'avez fait c'est vous
qui l'avait portée c'est vous qui l'avez
mis au monde
c'est ça qu'il faut c'est sûr ça qu'il
faut penser et réfléchir avant de
s'engager là dedans parce que parce
qu'après si une femme change d'avis
il ya un malaise ou un mal être que ça
soit pas génétiquement enfin etc etc je
sais pas ce que ça peut engendrer
derrière mais je pense que c'est des
complications et c'est ça qu'il faut
vraiment bien bien bien dosé bien pensé
si aurélie et l'euro sont aujourd'hui
des parents comblés ils le savent c'est
grâce un long parcours mené par la
donneuse passé par plusieurs entretiens
examens médicaux et de nous rentrer
ensuite dans une phase de stimulation de
l'ovulation qui dure une dizaine de
jours et correspond à des injections
d'hormones
le but c'est que les deux ans vers
travail en même temps et produisez on va
dire une dizaine douzaine d'hommes au
site
qu'ensuite on va prélever pendant cette
phase de traitement qui dure à peu près
une dizaine une douzaine de jours ce
sont des injections à faire de manière
quotidienne
et puis à quelques contrôles de crise de
sens et d'échographie pour s'assurer que
la stimulation et bien menée ce
traitement remboursés à 100% par la
sécurité sociale se termine par le
prélèvement d'ovocytes lors d'une courte
hospitalisation les étapes qui n'ont
jamais fait reculer cette donneuse
anonyme de 35 ans et mère de trois
enfants
moi j'ai eu beaucoup de chance j'ai eu
trois enfants sans difficulté
je me suis dit que c'était un juste
retour des choses puisque aujourd'hui je
veux plus d'enfants donc voilà je me
suis dit que c'était un juste
rééquilibrage de la nature les bilans et
toute la batterie d'examens non ça m'a
pas du tout effrayé je me suis dit de
toute façon si je si je veux faire ça
j'assume
j'assume tout les examens tous les
bilans
la seule chose qui m'a inquiété c'est
plutôt par rapport à mes propres enfants
les quais la façon dont est ce que
j'allais leur en parler si je leur en
parle est de quelle façon
comment était réparti les ovocytes dans
la population est ce que mes enfants
risquer un jour de rencontrer ce ou ces
enfants éventuellement conçu c'est
plutôt de ce côté là mes interrogations
on lui a répondu que statistiquement il
y avait très peu de chances que ces
enfants rencontrent ce n'est du don en
ile de france d'après les derniers
chiffres de 2011 on compte 111 donneuse
pour 651 couples en attente d'un don
d'ovocytes
il ya un manque criant de donneuses
il ya beaucoup plus de demandes de
nombreux tics de possibilités de dons à
l'heure actuelle ce qui expose les
couples à des délais d'attentes avant de
pouvoir bénéficier d'un don de quelque
fois plusieurs années le délai moyen
d'attenté d'environ deux ans à savoir
que ce type de danse gratuit anonyme et
volontaire ne peut se faire que dans un
hôpital public et dans les yvelines le
seul agrémenter et celui de poissy
au mesnil saint denis une maison de
retraite s'est vu offrir des tableaux
numériques interactifs
un cadeau du rotary club qui permet aux
personnes âgées de travailler leur
mémoire tout en découvrant les nouvelles
technologies reportage il ya encore
quelques mois dans cette maison de
retraite du mesnil-saint-denis marie
imprimer ces images sur papier et les
distribue retraités mais l'arrivée de ce
nouveau tableau numérique facilite
beaucoup de jeunes aux croyants de mia
mais non il est bien sur la photo
déjà le fait qu'ils soient grands qui
soit visible par tout le monde
ce qui était pas qu'avant puisque mon
tableau était beaucoup plus petit est un
format d'un mètre sur 70 dont visible
par tous diversifier les jeux
sauvegardés
ce tableau numérique permet une réelle
interactivité mari peut aussi aller sur
internet à tout moment un outil très
moderne pour ces personnes âgées qui
découvrent l'ère du numérique
j'avais peur un peu cueilli un peu
d'appréhension à l'utilisation passe
quelque chose de très moderne et puis en
fait elles sont venues vraiment très
très bien très facilement y'a qu'à
mettre un petit coup de crayon son côté
psa et voilà marina plus à essuyer déjà
elle efface comme elles veulent être
bâtiment où l'on peut très bien mais il
ya un autre fruit un petit fruit et vous
l'a vu avec ce nouvel outil ces
retraités peuvent maintenant travailler
leur mémoire dans de bonnes conditions
notamment la mémoire immédiate
celles qui perdent le plus en fait un la
mémoire immédiate ils ont souvent des
souvenirs de très lointain mais cette
mémoire proches elle disparaît vite
donc voilà on essaye de la stimuler et
vernis
c'est le bilan d'un travail mené pendant
plus de deux mois
attrape les membres des centres
socioculturels ont réalisé une
exposition sur le thème du cancer du
sein
nous avons rencontré il ya quelques
jours ils nous racontent leur expérience
au centre socioculturel des merisiers
attrape l'heure est au bilan
pendant plus de deux mois plusieurs
groupes ont été constitués pour
travailler sur le thème du cancer du
sein ont continué le médecin ayant
certains ont élaboré un glossaire des
termes techniques
d'autres se sont penchés sur les
différentes étapes du dépistage organisé
et quelques-uns ont même pu visiter le
service mammographie d'un hôpital de la
ville les clichés de leurs parcours sont
présentés au centre d'exposition
je vois qu'elles sont intégrées
complètement les messages donc du
dépistage tous les deux ans à partir de
50 ans à les voir régulièrement sa
gynéco sont des choses que qu'elle porte
et que les hommes portent puisqu'il y
avait des hommes aussi dans les groupes
parmi les hommes justement ça là au
départ pas franchement intéressé par le
sujet c'est en assistant à une pièce de
théâtre sur le cancer du sein en octobre
dernier qu'il a voulu s'impliquer dans
cette aventure nature
moi aussi m'intéresse pour ça parce que
parce que comme j'ai ma mère ma soeur
mais ma femme aussi
donc tout ça ça fait déjà un macaque moi
aussi que le médecin ne peut rien
deviner tout ça là bas nord il a fait
des études d'accord mais ça lui tombent
pas du ciel qui fait un diagnostic est
pas une
la vie en fonction aussi de ce co2
seront ils enfin le cancer du sein
c'est vrai on a entendu le mot cancer on
a peur parce que c'est le méchant
maladie mais comme ses dessins ça doit
être guéri on m'a détecté à sa précoce
l'exposition circule actuellement dans
tous les centres socioculturels de
trappes et pourquoi pas à l'avenir dans
d'autres communes de l'agglomération
on espère que ça va donc évoluer
on a déjà entendu ce soir les femmes qui
ont dit qu'elle était d'accord pour en
parler ailleurs
donc pour moi c'est vraiment une chance
qui nous est donnée puisque en fait on
sait que la parole des femmes
elle compte beaucoup plus que celle d'un
professionnel de santé
même si le professionnel le médecin il a
toute sa place
on sait que les femmes elles portent
beaucoup plus le message autour d'elle
et elles sont plus convaincantes que
n'importe quelle autre personne
ce numéro de check up touche à sa fin
avant de nous quitter jetons un coup
d'oeil sur l'agenda et sur ce qu'il faut
retenir le mardi 25 février l'espace
santé active de versailles vous propose
un atelier bien-être des 17 heures un
atelier gratuit et animés par des
professionnels de santé à montigny le
bretonneux une collecte mobile de don du
sang est organisée ce sera le jeudi 20
février de 14h à 19h30 au centre
commercial espace saint quentin check up
c'est terminé merci de votre attention
je vous donne rendez-vous dans un mois
d'ici là portez vous bien